merci monsieur ministre la parole est à
madame véronique louwagie
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse solistes de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la forêt et porte
sur les aides de la politique agricole
commune de 2015 pour lesquelles je
regrette monsieur le ministre de devoir
vous interrogez de nouveau en effet à ce
jour le versement des aides liées à ces
droits n'est toujours pas effectif or
dans votre réponse du 19 avril dernier à
ma question écrite du 15 mars
vous indiquez je vous cite s'agissant
des aides couplées animal à la vache
allaitante vaches laitières
celles ci seront versés fin avril début
mai c'était de trésorerie est tendue
sera intégralement assurée sur crédits
de l'état ce qui représente environ 500
millions d'euros
elle interviendra au mois d'avril
prochain nous sommes le 11 mai et nombre
d'éleveurs sont toujours dans la tente
par ailleurs les avances de trésorerie
remboursables octroyées selon les
situations de chacun ne sont pas des
alternatives satisfaisantes
lundi dernier le président de la
république est allé inaugurer une halle
destinés à l'agriculture biologique à
rungis
il a assuré que le solde des aides de la
politique agricole commune pour 2015
sera versé aux agriculteurs heures je
cite avants lafond le cdt monsieur le
ministre
alors même que les déclarations de
pâques 2016 sont réalisés en ce moment
même par les agriculteurs les droits à
paiement de base 2015 déterminée au
regard de la surface admissibles ne sont
pas versées c'est insoutenable
les agriculteurs ne connaissent toujours
pas les impacts financiers liés aux
critères de verdissement et aux surfaces
non agricoles cela engendre finalement
une deuxième déclaration pac à l'aveuglé
pour nombre d'exploitations agricoles
cette absence de visibilité fragile un
secteur déjà en crise alors même que ces
aides sont censé stabiliser la
trésorerie des exploitations nos
agriculteurs se sentent abandonnés que
leur dire face à ces dysfonctionnements
qui décrédibilise le système dans son
ensemble les regards à vos kélian
informatique laisse aujourd'hui pantois
de nombreux agriculteurs
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
répondre avec précision sur
ces points à quelle date les
agriculteurs recevront si l'apport
l'état monsieur stéphane le foll
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt madame
me
madame la députée monsieur le président
mais madame la députée surtout ne
regrettez pas de me poser des questions
c'est avec grand plaisir que j'y réponds
en particulier sur cette question là
vous demander pourquoi il ya un retard
sur les aides et le versement des aides
je voudrais simplement vous rappeler que
nous avons été soumis à ce qu'on appelle
un apurement liés à des versements des
aides entre 2008 et 2012 qui nous a
obligés négociations conduites vis-à-vis
de la commission
asper l'ensemble du registre parcellaire
graphique 25 millions d'hectares madame
la députée ont été revus
rephotographiées par des satellites et
obliger tous les services de l'état a
travaillé durant l'année 2015 à remettre
en ordre
l'ensemble de ce parti par césar
graphique hectares par hectare nous
avons donc perdu du temps et nous
essayons de rattraper ce temps pour
éviter que les agriculteurs soient
victimes de ce qui a été une erreur du
passé et que j'assume
en tant que ministre aujourd'hui nous
avons versé des avances à la fin de
l'année 2015 de l'ordre de 90% des aides
le solde le président de la république
l'a annoncé sera versée avant le 10
septembre ce qui reste des aides de 2015
madame la députée et nous faisons le
plus vite que nous pouvons sur l'année
2016 qui verra la mise en oeuvre de la
politique agricole commune 2015 2016
là il y aura des avances qui seront
faites encore une fois dès le mois
d'octobre à 90%
parce que les agriculteurs ont besoin
d'être soulagé en termes de trésorerie
même si je le dis les aides de la
politique agricole commune ne sont pas
prévu a priori pour l'exemple dès le
mois d'octobre
90 pour sauver la terre et le solde de
l'ensemble de ces aides sera versée
début 2017 et nous ont rattrapés ainsi
le retard que nous avons eues en 2015
à cause de l'apurement euros